[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من العربيه احييكم وهذه نشره الخامسه انا
ريما مكتبي نبدا بابرز العناوين هذا الجسر
يفصل بين الدولتين اوكرانيا
في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
على الحدود بين اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا
امكانيه تقديم موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والتشريعيه المقرره هذا العام
الثالث الجمهوريون يبحثون عن توافق ينهي
ازمه رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
مقاتلات باكستانيه تقصف مواقع طالبان
باكستان داخل افغانستان وعوده التوتر على
الحدود
عزز الجيش الاوكراني من تواجده في الحدود
مع دوله بيلاروسيا عبر انشاء دفاعات
هندسيه وزرع الالغام على كامل الحدود بين
دولتين خشيه الزحف الى اكياس من الجانب
البيلاروسي واوضحت الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في ما سبق ان موسكو استخدمت
بيلاروسيا منطلقه للحرب بعد نشر الالاف من
قواتها في الحدود لل الهجوم على كياف
واطلقت صواريخ من قواعد جويه بلا روسيه
في غضون ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع في
بيلاروسيا انها ستجرى مناورات الجويه
مشتركه مع روسيا
واشارت في بيان لها الى اتفاق مع روسيا
على زياده المناورات العسكريه المشتركه
التي تجريها البلدان وكانت بلاروسيا
وروسيا اجرتها مناورات البريه مشتركه
الشهر الماضي
مع ان الحدود الاوكرانيه البيلاروسيه
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بيك حذيفه
كيف هي الاجواء من ذلك الجانب هل ممكن
مشاهده بالعين المجرده التعزيزات العسكريه
ام انها همم بعمق الحدود
تحياتي ريما في الحقيقه انا الان اقف
تماما في الحدود الاوكرانيه البلاروصيه
وهذه نقطه العبور كما تشاهدين امامك في
التعزيزات يمكن ان نراها بالعين المجرده
رصدت تعزيزات الاوكرانيه هنالك انتشار
واسع للقوات الاوكرانيه هنالك عمليه زرع
للغام كبيره جدا الجنود هنا يقولون لنا ان
لا نتحرك في اي اتجاه الا بعد التاكد من
سلامه المنطقه لان الالغام مزروعه في كل
مكان ونحن في الطريق الى هنا في المناطق
القريبه من الحدود شاهدنا الجنود وهم
يقومون بعمليات الحفر والالغام بجانبهم
يقومون بعمليات زرع الالغام شاهدنا عمليه
الزرع على الانغام في بعض الجسور على
الطريق همم يعني عمليه تلقيم للجسور نفسها
شاهدنا ذلك كذلك افعدونا بان هذا الامر في
كامل الحدود بين الدولتين هنالك الجدار
طبعا تم انشاءه وما زال المهندسين يوصلون
عمليه او التشييد لهذا الجدار الفاصل بين
الدولتين هنالك خنادق تم حفرها في الحدود
كذلك هنالك دوريات وتنشيط يتم على مدار
الساعه ومراقبه على مدار الساعه للاجواء
وليه ايضا عمليات التحرك بري ممكن وكذلك
طبعا نهر الدينيبر الذي يفصل ما بين
الدولتين هنالك عمليات مراقبه ودوريات تتم
على نهر لحتى لضمان عدمور القوات البلاله
الروسيه او الروسيه لانها طبعا القوات
الروسيه متمركز على بعد 400 متر فقط من
الحدود يمكن من الجسر الذي تم تدميره من
هذه النقطه يمكن رؤيتهم بالعين المجرده
وهم ايضا يقومون بمراقبه الحدود بالمقابل
حذيفه
في القرى والمناطق المحيطه كيف هو وضع
الميدانيين والسكان
يعني بالنسبه
للشيء المفاجئ طبعا هذه الولايه عملنا
فيها كثيرا في الفتره الاولى للحرب ولكن
الان يعني المفاجئ بالنسبه لي ان هنالك
عوده كبيره جدا للمواطنين في هذه الولايه
وكان في الكره او في مدينه شريفه نفسها
هنالك استقرار هنالك حركه حتى يعني
الكهرباء التي
وكثير من المناطق من المشاكل فيها قالوا
لي السكان انه نادره ما يتم قطع الكهرباء
لا يتوقعون اي حركه او عمليات الهجوم في
الوقت الحالي ولكن طبعا هذا السيناري غير
مستبعد همم الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاخرانيه تقول انه هنالك سناريا قد يكون
ولكن ليس الان قد يحدث هذا الامر في شهر
مارس القادم ان يكون هنالك جديده ودخول
الى اما الى كيف او الى الولايات الغربيه
كل الكاميرا ان توسع همم زاويه ونرى
الحدود بعض الشيء من خلفك انه التصوير
محظور
يعني في هذا الاتجاه نعم في الاتجاه
المقابل ممنوع وستعب قليلا يمكنكم ان
تشاهد هنا هذه نقطه التفتيش والعابور في
الحدود والتي هي اغلقت تماما طبعا الحدود
مغلقه لذلك هذه النقطه الان لا تعمل الان
يوجد فقط تواجد طبعا حرص الحدود نفسه
الذين كانوا متواجدين هنا الان تحولوا الى
قوات مقاتله هم يقاتلون على الحدود وهم
يقومون بحراسه الحدود وكذلك الجيش همم
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه القوات الخاصه
ايضا هي متواجده هنا في هذا المكان هنالك
عدد وكذلك قوات الدفاع الاقليميه ايضا
متواجدا المدعيه ايضا متواجده تم تعزيز
الحدود بعد عدد كبير من الجنود تم ارسال
اللواء الثامن والخمسين من منطقه تم
ارساله الى مثلث الحدود الروسيه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه همم هذا هو شكل التعزيزات التي
قامت بها اكيد كيفيه تقول انها مطمئنه الى
الوضع في الحدود
وانه اذا ما كان هنالك اي تقدم من قبل
القوات الروسيه او البلا الروسيه يمكنها
ان تحسم ذلك في الوقت الحالي وهي اا ال-
يعني ليس لديها مخاوف من امكانيه الوصول
الى كيف كما جرى في المره الاولى كانت
الوصول سهلا جدا طبعا تقدمت القوات
واستطاعت بسهوله كبيره طبعا تعلمين ان هذه
الحدود هي اقرب حدود الى العاصمه كيف من
النقطه التي فيها انا الان ثلاثه ساعات
ويكون الانسان في مركز العاصمه كثير
لكن ليس اوروبا
الدبابات العسكريه عن السير او السياره
العاديه شكرا لك حتى اللحظه كان معي من
الحدود الاوكرانيه البيلاروسيا مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عدل شكرا لك
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها تمكنت من اسقاط 21 مسير اوكرانيه و
خمسه صواريخ من طراز هاي مارس في يوم واحد
واضافت وزاره في بيان ان عملياتها
العسكريه اسفلت عن مقتل اكثر من 250
عسكريا اوكرانيا
وتدمير قذفتيه صواريخ اوكرانيتين في
دونتستك
دمرت القوات الروسيه 60% من مدينه بخموت
الواقعه في منطقه دوناتس بشرق اوكرانيا
رئيس الاداره العسكريه في اوكرانيا اوضح
ان محاولات القوات الروسيه اقتحامه محمود
تلك القوات الى مواقع السابقه خارج حدود
المدينه
هذا وقالت وصف الجنه لان روسيا خفضت
عمليتها الهجوميه في مدينه بخمود
باوكرانيا الصحيفه اشارت نقلا عن عسكريين
اوكرانيين الا ان روسيا تخلت عن هدف
الاستيلاء على باخموت
لافتينا الى ان روسيا بدات اختبار دفاعات
الاوكرانيه حول سوليدار
حتى الان
عاقبه قتال عنيف شهيده تلك المنطقه الايام
الماضيه
المكان هذا يكتسب اهميه كبيره بالنسبه
للروز اقلها معنويا
كعب الجنود عسكريا مع بس سيطرتهم على
مناطق واسعه اما اوكرانيا فتسعى بكل قوتها
للحفاظ على المدينه وحمايتها فيما اعلن
قاده الجيش فيها فشل القوه الروسيه مشينا
الى ان المقاومه القويه اجبرت روسيا على
تحويل اتجاه من ناحيه مناطق اخرى محيطه
احتضنت المدينه قبل الحرب نحو 70,000 شخص
بعد مرور 10 اشهر على الحرب المستعره لم
يبقى فيها سوا ثم السكان اذا شن الجيش
الروسي ومجموعه هجوما واسع النطاق تمثل
المدينه الاوكرانيا حسما دفاع في منطقه
الدونتس ولروسيا تشكل بوابه استراتيجيه
لسيطره على كامل دومباز
هناك حصن في كل منزل في بخمط احيانا
يستغرق تطير المنزل اسابيع كامله اليس
كذلك
وروسيا تبقى مخموت محطه مهمه تدخل معها
الحرب نفقا جديدا حسم مالاته معلق بين
فوهات هذه المدافع وتل
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
كان الاعلى اليوم بعد يعني الضربه التي
تلقتها روسيا من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في
مدينه مكه اليوم
اعلت حليه او المرصد المحلي عن مقتل مدني
واصابه اخر كما ان الصواريخ والقذائف التي
سقطت على المدينه بشتى همم ضواحيها وعلى
المقاطعه مدامها وصلت الى اقل من 400
قديمه وصاروخ كما ان ال ال
الروسي هو اعنف واكثر بكثير همم
الحديث عن تاوي اضعاف اضافات
همم يعني ارسال عسكريه ما زالت تتنقل هنا
من منطقه الى منطقه ونحن شهود ايام على
ذلك بفعل هناك كميات كبيره او اعدادات كان
كثيرا للجنود الرؤوس الا يتنونه
هلا بامكان لاحد ان يخرج ويقضي حاجاته ان
يسير اموره خلال النهار
منذ الصباح الباكر كما اسلفت كانت
العمليات العسكريه عنيفه جدا وكان السكون
يعم المدينه منذ ساعتين تقريبا وتوقفت
الاعمال العسكريه ربما ان يكون
هذا بالطرحه الذي طرحته الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه في موسكو
باجراء هدنا تزامنا ذكرى
عيد الميلاد المجيد الشرقي ااه الان هناك
هدوء ربما يخرج بعض الناس همم بشكل افراد
ل- اا المحلات لتسوق او لقضاء حاجتهم لكن
همم اعداد قليله يعني لو كانت يعني لو كان
الوضع مناسبا كنا همم لكن اسمحي لي بما ان
اعرج على مساله
مكانك في التقارير المحليه هنا يعني تسليط
الضوء على مدينه باخمط وما تشهده من معارك
قالت هنا المصادر العسكريه بان ال
ال
رائد الاقتصاد سيء جدا
بالبرد والسقعه
والخطر ولكن الاتصال سيء جدا
هل ممكن التكمله
تقاتل في مدينه فاطمه على اطرافها من
ثلاثه واحد وتفوقه
ووسعت هذا الطوق ليشمل بلده سندار التي
تعتبر متاخمه
القوات الاوكرانيه التي انسحبت من مدينه
تطويق المدينه والبلده معا والحديث عن
اعمال عسكريه
عنيفه جدا في ذلك المحور وشرسه
وتقول المعلومات والمصادر لدينا هنا بان
الجيش الروسي همم يبلي بلاءا كبيرا في ذلك
المحور
شكرا جزيلا لك من دوناتسك مراسل العربيه
رائد الاخبار يعطيك الف عافيه
اعلن الكريم لان رئيس روسيف لازم يفوتن
قبل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
باستعداده للانفتاح على الحوار مع
اوكرانيا اذا قبلت كيف باعتبار الاراضي
الواقعه تحت سيطره موسكو بانها روسيه
واضاف لكريم في بيان ان بوتين اكد مره
اخرى على الحوار الجاد بشرط انت في سلطات
كيف
بالمتطلبات المعروفه والمعبره مرارا عن
مراعاه الحقائق الاقليميه الجديده وفق ما
جاء في البيان
وفي نشره الخامسه ولكن بعد فاصل
كوريا الجنوبيه تقول ان مسيره كوريا
الشماليه دخلت منطقه حظر طيران فوق مكتب
الرئاسه في سوريا
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان امكانيه تعديل موعد الانتخابات
التشريعيه ورئاسيه لتقام هذا العام بدلا
من عام 2024
جعلنا اردوغان بتبكير الانتخابات في وقت
قررت المحكمه الدستوريه في تركيا حرمانه
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه الموالي للاكراد
مؤقتا من المخصصات الماليه
قبل اقل من سته اشهر من موعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التشريعيه بسبب اتهاماء اتهام
سلطات للحزب بصلاه مع الارهاب
قررت المحكمه الدستوريه في تركيا اذا
حرمان حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الموالي
للاكراد كما ذكرنا مؤقتا من المخصصات
الماليه
وكنا ذكرنا هذا الخبر قبل لحظات
وقال ايضا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
انه قد يجتمع مع نظيره السوري بشار الاسد
من اجل السلام في المنطقه واضاف اردوغان
انه بحث مع الرئيس الروسي فلازم
الاجتماعات التركيه الروسيه السوريه مشيرا
الى امكانيه عقد اجتماعي لقاده البلدان
الثلاثه حسب التطورات واكد رئيس تركيا انه
وزراء خارجيه تركيا وروسيا وسوريا يعتزمون
الاجتماع خلال الفتره المقبله
اصدرت محكمه ايرانيه الحكم بالاعدام على
رجل المتهم بالارتباط بحركه الاحتجاجات
التي اندلعت في البلاد في منتصف سبتمبر
بعد مقتل الشابه معينه وفقا لموقع موزان
اون لاين التابع للسلطه القضائيه فقط قضت
المحكمه باعدام عرشه
وذلك بسام قيادته لاعمال شغب في مدينه
وشهر شمال
بحق شخصين بحسب منظمات الحقوقيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يبدو ان حمله تقع الشرطه الايرانيه التي
مورست ضد المحتاجين لم تكن كافيه بنسبه
للنظام حيث تشير الانباء الى اقاله قائد
الشرطه حسين الشريف
انباء برنا الايرانيه التابعه لوزاره
الرياضه والشباب بانتهاء مهمه اشتري في
قياده الشرطه ليحل محله احمد رضا ردان
قائد شرطه طهران السابق لكن وسائل الاعلام
الايرانيه المعارضه شدت على ان السبب يرجع
لفشل اشتري في كبح لاحتجاجات المستمره منذ
منتصف سبتمبر الماضي
الشريعه الذي عين في منصبه عام 2015 وجهت
لهم انتقادات من خامنئي نفسه بحسب قناه
ايران انترناشونال لعدم كفاءته في ايقاف
تمدد الاحتجاجات وبنظر الى تاريخ اشتري
الذي بدا حياته في صفوف الحارس الثوري
وكان احد قاده قم معي لاحتجاجات السابقه
التي كان اخرها عام 19 فان انباء اقالته
تشير الى مدى تسع الغضب وربما القلق داخل
النظام من استمراريه لاحتجاجات وزخمها
وفي سلسله متواصله من احراق صور قائد
الفيلق القدس السابق والحرس الثوري
الايراني قاسم سليماني اصبح المتظاهرون
اكثر تحديا للسلطات حيث احرقوا الصوره
نهارا في احد الميادين المزدحمه باصفهان
فيما هتفه مصور المقطع بالموت للديكتاتور
ما اعرف بعد
وقع الشباك بين قوه طالبان وحرس الحدود
الباكستاني في مع باريس رقم الحدودي بين
البلدين وفق اعلى من افغاني وبدات قوته
طالبان اطلاق النار على الجانب
الباكستانيه ما اذى لاصابه جنديا
الباكستانيه بالمقابل رد حرس الحدود
الباكستاني باطلاق النار الامر الذي ادى
الى مقتل مواطن افغاني
قبل ذلك ذكرت صحف الافغانيه ان قوه الجويه
الباكستانيه جنه غرات جويه على معاق
الحركه طالبان باكستان داخل الاراضي
الافغانيه مع الحدود مع باكستان واضافت ان
المقاتلات الباكستانيه قصفت مواقع طالبان
باكستان بولايتناغهار
شقيقه افغانستان ياتي هذا بعد ثلاثه ايام
من اعلان مجلس الامن القومي الباكستاني
تنفيذ قارات العسكريه على معاقل الحركه
داخل افغانستان
معي من قبل مراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر
عبد الله كيف هو الوضع على الحدود الان
الوضع الان تهدا بحسب اخر ما وصلنا من
الاخبار من ممر خيبر الشهير تورخم اييه
بعد قتل احد حراس الحرس
الافغاني بحسبه ما قالته المصادر التابعه
لطالبان واصيب في الاشتباكات احد الحراس
الباكستانيين
والوضع الان تهدئ
والمسافرون يعبرون المعبر بكل امان وسلامه
فيما هذه المعابر همم بين الحدود
الافغانيه والباكستانيه همم تتعرض
لاشتباكات بين فين واخر والمباحثات التي
تم اجرائها بين طرفين لحد الان همم لم تصل
الى اي نتيجه وليست هناك استراتيجيه واضحه
لهذه المعابر بين البلدين باكستان
وافغانستان همم يعني
فهذا التوتر
لاسباب ان همم عده يعني احيانا هناك
المسافرون الافغاني يعبرون هذه المعابر
ويتعرضون
بحسب اا ال- عناصر طالبان للاساءه في في
الذهاب والاتيان الى الداخل الى الافغاني
ثم ااا يغضب العناصر الطالبانيه ويشتبكون
مع القوات الباكستانيه هذا هو السبب
الواضح وليست هناك اسباب اخرى فان هذه
المعابر تعبرها ويعبرها الاف همم من
المسافرين الافغان بين باكستان وافغانستان
همم حدوده هذه المعابر مزدحمه كما تعرفها
رحلات وقوافل همم تجاريه همم كبيره جدا
يوميا وبشكل يومي
داخل الحكومه طالبان هل هم على همم يعني
اهبات الاستعداد لاي تصعيد على الحدود مع
باكستان هل هم جاهزون لتوتر او الساعه او
عنف او ساعه
التصريحات الذي صرح بها رانا ثناء الله
بان القوات الباكستانيه ستنفذ عمليات داخل
الاراضي الافغانيه فان سلطات في كابول هذه
التصريحات اثارت حفيظه سلطات في كابول
ونحن قرانا سمعنا انتقادات الذي وتصريحات
لوزير الدفاع الافغاني محمد يعقوب وندد
بهذه التصريحات باغلظ الالفاظ وقال ان
افغانستان همم دوله همم ابنائها مستعدون
للدفاع عنها وهذا يعني ان همم الجانب
الافغاني مستعد لتصعيد اذا همم تطالب
الامر ولكن ال- ال- الجانب الباكستاني
ياخذ حيطه
لان الجانب الافغاني همم يعني خرج من
الحرب الطويله ولم يهدى له مش وبالتالي
الجانب الافغاني فيما يبدو انه مستعد
للحرب والقتال ولكن الجانب الباكستاني همم
يعني ياخذ من المرونه همم والتفاهم مع
الجانب الافغاني شكرا السلطات الافغانيه
وليست هناك تصريحات
لكلى الجانبين حول التصعيد لحد الان
عبد الله
الافغانيات بقرار من حكومه طالبان بات ثلث
عدد السكان في انتظار كارثه انسانيه بسبب
توقف عمل المنظمات غير الحكوميه من جانبها
حضارات واشنطن طالبان من تداعيات قرارها
ضد النساء اذا لم تتراجع بينما سيبحث مجلس
الامن التطبيق على الافغانيات في اجتماع
المغلق الاسبوع المقبل
بقراراتها المثيره للجدل في افغانستان
ووضعت حكومه طالبا نفسها امام ضغوط دوليه
هائله بسبب تضيقها على النساء ففي الوقت
الذي يستعد مجلس الامن الدولي للانقاضي
للبحث الازمه اعلنت واشنطن انها تدرس
الاختيارات لدفع طالبان للتراجع عن قرار
حضر عمل الافغانيات في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه المنظمات تلعب دورا اساسيا في
محاوله معالجه واحده من اسوء الازمات
الانسانيه في العالم حيث يعيش سبعه 97% من
الافغان في فقط وثلث السكان بحاجه
للمساعدات للبقاء على قيد الحياه مع
مواجهه 20 مليون شخص الجوع الشديد بحاسب
المتحده تلك المنظمات التي تعتبر حيويه
وضروريه في افغانستان مهدده بالانهيار
فحذر عمل الافغانيات ترك فجوه كبيره في
الدعم المنقذ للحياه واصفه قرارات طالبان
بالتميزيه اذا
من المستحيل مواصلات وانشطتنا اذا لم يكن
لدينا موظفات الشتاء الماضي كانت
المساعدات الانسانيه هي التي جنبت وقوع
مجاعه اذا لم نتمكن من تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه بالطريقه نفسها فسنواجه وضع
المروع للغايه اكثر من الف ومئتين منظمه
غير حكوميه تعمل في افغانستان منها اربعه
منظمات دوليه كما تعليقه عملياتها لعدم
قدرتها على اداره برامجها دون موظفات في
مجالات رعايه الصحيه والتعليم والمياه
والصرف الصحي ومع اسرار طالبان بان
المساعدات لم تتاثر بقراراتها فستجد
افغانستان التي تعتمد بالكامل تقريبا على
المساعدات نفسها امام كارثه انسانيه ستعصف
بالملايين في المستقبل القريب رشا خياط
العربيه
والسبب يعود الى عوامل اولها البرد وسوء
التغذيه كذلك العقوبات الغربيه
عمل النساء في المنظمات غير الحكوميه ماذا
دفع اكثر من 180 منظمه دوليه لتعليق
عملياتها في اشهر الشتاء
وفي سياق اخر وقع وزير التعديل في حكومه
طالبان بافغانستان عقدا مع شركه صينيه
لاستخراج النفط شبه البلاد واشار الى ان
احتياطيا نفط الخام في المنطقه المستهدفه
يقدر بنحو 1.8 مليار برميل
بنحوي مليار و800 مليون برميل المشروع
الحالي يقع في منطقتك اشكاري بولايه
ساريبول في موقع مهم جدا على مساحه
4500 كلم وباستثمار 150 مليون دولار وقد
يستخرج منه من الف الى 20,000 طن من النفط
الخام هيرضى مود رياضيه
افادت مصادر العربيه بان رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي لفريق اول ركن عبد
الفتاح البرهان يقود وساطه لتقريب المواقف
بين كتل الحريه والتغيير الثلاث وهي
المجلس المركزي والكتله ديمقراطيه والقوى
الوطنيه
برعايه البرهان ناقشت خلالها عددا من
الملفات من بينها الاتفاق الاطاري ورؤيه
كل كتله لمرحله ما بعد الفتره الانتقاليه
واكد المتاحات وان قائد ثاني قوات الدعم
السريع الفريق عبد الرحيم قد سهل اجتماعين
للكتل لنفسها في منزله لذات الغرض
وفي ليبيا اكد رئيس البرلمان عقيل صالح
اليوم ان مجلس النواب اتفق مع المجلس
الاعلى للدوله على القيام بكل ما يلزم
للوصول الى انتخابات في اقرب الاجل وقال
صالح في مؤتمر صحفي بالقاهره انه جرى
تحقيق تقارب كبير مع المجلس الاعلى للدوله
خلال المباحثات المشتركه ومن جهته اكد
رئيس مجلس الدوله خالد المشاري انه يسعى
بكل وضوح لتدليله كافه العقبات امام اجراء
انتخابات البرلمانيه ورئاسيه في ليبيا بكل
تجارب وبعيدا عن اي مصالح
عندما
قلت بالتاكيد نحن نحتاج الى سوبر موحده في
ليبيا للانتخابات
هذه الحكومه ستكون هناك اليه سابقه اللي
تمت في همم في الانتقالات
جديده وتكوين احنا شوفنا جديده بالاتفاق
بين المجلسين ان شاء الله في الايام
القادمه سيعلن هذا الامر في لقاء بيننا
وبين الرئيسين في منطقه داخل ليبيا عن خطه
الطريق الجديده في الايام القادمه باذن
الله
اصدرت انياب العموميه بهيئه القضاء
المليفي تونس امرا بالتحفظ على نحو عشره
قيادات لحركه النهضه ورجال اعمال موقفين
بسبب شبهات تبييض الاموال وفق اعلام
المحليا تونسيه كما ادرجت نيابه اخرين في
التفتيش لتحصنهم بالفرار او تواجدهم خارج
البلاد يذكر عموميه بالمحكمه الابتدائيه
بتونس اصدرت منذ اسبوع امرا بالاحتفاظ
بالقياديه السابق بحركه النهضه والعضو
بجمعيه نماء تونس عبد الكريم سليمان بسبب
شبهات في تبييض الاموال
اكل الجيش الكوري الجنوبيه ان مسيره كوريا
الشماليه اخترقت منطقه حضر الطيران حول
المكتب رئاسي خلال التوغل النادر الشهر
الماضي كانت قد نفته في السابق وارسلتهم
خمس مسيرات عبر الحدود الى المجال الجوي
لكوريا الجنوبيه في 26 من كانون الاول
الماضي وهو اول حادث من نوعه منذ خمس
سنوات ماذا
كان الجيش الكوري الجنوبيه
من المسايرات رغم عمليه استمر
ذلك بان المسيارات صغيره جدا
وفي نشره الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
على خطط تويتر امازون تسرح اكثر من ثمانيه
عشره الف موظف والبدايه هذا الشهر
اهلا بكم من جديد يستعد مجلس النواب
الامريكي لعقد جلسه لليوم الثالث على
التوالي الانتخابي رئيسا له وكان المجلس
علق اعماله الى منتصف اليوم بعد سبع جلسات
تصويت الفاشله لانتخاب لانتخاب من يخلف
نانسي
لدعم الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب الذي سيطر
عليه الجمهوريون بعد الانتخابات النصفيه
في نوفمبر
من جانبه اعلن رئيس مجلس اداره شركه تويزر
الون ماسك دعمه لتوالي كيفن مكاسي
منصبه رئاسه مجلس النواب جاء ذلك عبر
تغريده مقتضب له على تويتر قال فيها انما
الكرسي يجب ان يكون رئيسا للمجلس مجلس
النواب دعم مصر جاء بعد فشل الاخير في حسم
المنصب بعد ست جولات من التصويت والاتجاه
لجوله السابعه
العربيه
جوله سابعه اليوم ماذا نتوقع
تحيه لك ريما ااا ما نتوقعه وهو اييه
اجواء ايجابيه تم الحديث عنها البارحه بعد
ماراثون من المحادثات ومن الاجتماعات بين
الاعضاء الجمهوريين ومع مكار في تحديدا
لكنما كرت نفسه قال البارحه انه لم
يتوصلوا الى اتفاق وحتى المراقبون هنا لا
يتوقعون حدوث اختراق اليوم ولكن ايضا بحسب
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه همم قدم مكان في
العديد من التنازلات حتى البارحه فمثلا
على مستوى همم الاصوات او عدد الاصوات
المطلوبه للمضيق قدما باجراء تصويت على
عزل رئيس مجلس النواب مكرره الان قبل ان
يكون هناك عضو واحد يطالب بذلك ليتم
التصويت على هذا الامر وهو اصلا كان قدم
تنازلات عندما قبل ان يكون هناك خمسه
اعضاء فقط من الجمهوريين يطالبون بهذا
الاجراء بدل نصف عدد الجمهوريه في مجلس
النواب ايضا من المعلومات التي وصلتنا
بانه قبل زياده عدد
الجمهوريين الذين يوصفون بالمتشددين في
لجنه القواعد في مجلس النواب وهي اللجنه
التي تناقش التشريعات خاصه التشريعات التي
تعنى بالانفاق الحكومي قبل ارسالها الى
مجلس النواب يتم التصويت عليها هناك عدد
من الامور التي تنازل عنها ايضا مكارتي
ولكن ليس من الواضح حتى الان اذا كان
هؤلاء المتشددون في الحسبه الجمهوري
سيسوطون عليه لان التصريحاتهم البارحه لم
تكن تصب في هذا المجال العديد منهم قالوا
نعم هناك جو ايجابي هناك همم امكانيه
للتواصل الى اتفاق ولكن ليس لصالح مكار في
لن يصوت عليه ربما سيصوطون على مرشحين اخر
ربما يتم التوافق عليه وهذه المعلومات
كانت راشد في الايام الماضيه عندما كان
هناك حديث عن امكانيه اما مرشح اخر من
الجمهوريهم عليه اتفاق بين الجمهوريين
وادي الديمقراطيين على مرشح توافقين ولكن
بشكل عام هناك اجواء ايجابيه ولكن ليس من
المتوقع ان يحدث اختراق اليوم بحسب
المحللين وبحسب وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
عده اذا اليوم فشله ايضا ااه الانتخاب همم
هل تبقى الجلسات على هذا المنوال متى يقرر
مكارس مثلا انه لاحظ له عليه التنحي
بدا الجلسات من من اليوم الاول قبل الجلسه
الاولى هو قال ان هو مستعد للذهاب حتى
النهايه هو يشدد ويصر على انه زعيم جمهوري
يقول انه لديه الاغلبيه لديه الان 2002
عضو يصوتن لصالحه هناك 20 عضوا فقط هم ضده
هذه قليه بالنسبه له ولكن طبعا هي اقليه
فعاله كما اثبتتات لكن ما كان يبدو انه لن
يتنازل هذا من صرح به سابقا واكد عليه
واشار في احدى لقاءاته بانه هو صاحب اطول
خطاب في مجلس النواب في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده هو مستعد لان يكون صاحب يعني يكون
في اطول جلسات همم تصويت حتى النهايه
المهم انه سيفوز يعتقد ويسعى كما حاول
سابقا بان يخفض عتبه همم الاصوات المطلوبه
لفوجه برئاسه مجلس النواب من 218 صوتا الى
212 ذلك من خلال اقناع معارضيه من
الامتناع او التصويت بحاضر هو يحاول حتى
الان ولكن ليس من المؤكد انه اذا كان
سينجح لاسيما في ضل اصرار همم الجمهوريين
المتشددين في المجلس شكرا لك انا معي من
واشنطن مراسل العربيه احسن صوت
تشهد حركه النقل في بريطانيا المزيد من
الاضطرابات بفعل اضراب سائقي قطارات اذ
تتوقف غالبيه القطارات عن العمل ويعمل ما
لا يزيد عن 25% منها ويؤثر الاضراب الذي
تنفذه نقابه سائقي قطارات على عمله 15
شركه مشغله لسكك الحديد غالبيتها في
انجلترا لكن عددا قليلا منها يوفر خدمات
نحو اسكتلندا ويوس
من الواضح ان التضخما قد تجاوز الحد الناس
يكافحون لمنع انفسهم من الغرق المادي
يستحقون زياده في الاجور لقد عملوا طوال
الوباء على مدى ثلاث سنوات لضمان تشغيل
سكك الحديد لذا سيستمر القتال من الواضح
ان الحكومه تقوم باغلاق الشركات القطارات
وشبكه السكك الحديديه للتفاوض معنا
سيجري اميننا العام حدثات الاسبوع المقبل
لذا سيتعين علينا الانتظار ونرى كيف ستصير
الامور
معي من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
مصطفى هل ممكن ان تشعر بوضوح تاثير
الاضرابات في الشارع مثلا كنا نشاهد
طوابير امام الباصات بعض الناس لم تاتي
الى الاعمال في الاسابيع الماضيه هل هو
المشهد اليوم
بالفعل وهناك انتقاد كبير
لركاب الذين
يعني سالتهم حول تجربتهم باخذ قطار من
مدينه الى مدينه ولكن يعني اريد ان اطلعكم
على الشاشه الالكترونيه لا رحلات القطار
داخل محطه كينج كروس عاده ما تكون مليئه
كل هذه الشاشات يعني تقريبا هناك يعني
تقريبا شيء همم سته شاشات يعني فارغه بسبب
تعليق خدمات 15 شركه مشغله للقطارات في
مختلف البلاد وخاصه في وسط وسط انجلترا
وجنوبها وبالتالي هذا اثر على حركه تنقل
الناس من مكان الى اخر هناك انتقاد كبير
حتى ان اسعار بعض الرحلات المحدوده هي
اعلى بكثير من ما عليه كنت كنت يعني قبل
لحظات فقط جاءت سيده بحقيبه تقول بان دفعت
40 جنيه زياده على تذكرتها للوصول الى هذه
المحطه
الشركات التي تشغل القطارات اليوم هي
محدوده ولكن نسب قليله من القطارات تنقل
هؤلاء والكثير منهم فضلوا ان يبقوا في
البيت او حتى يعني للعمل من البيت مثلا او
حتى همم محاوله تاخير همم يعني رحلاتهم
الى في في وقت ما خاصه وان هذا الاضراب
لسكك الحديث سينتهي همم يوم السبت ولكن
الحركه التي تعود كما كانت عليه قبل هذه
الاضطرابات ربما يتطلب بعض الوقت لنقل
مثلا همم القطارات الى مكانها قبل ان تبدا
الرحلات بشكل اعتيادي ولكن نتوقع المزيد
من هذه الاضطرابات في همم الاسابيع
والاشهر المقبله يجب ان تعطي النقابات همم
ثلاث اسبوعين على الاقل قبل بدء موعد
الاداره وبالتالي تبدو ان نقابات يعني همم
عازمه على التصعيد الموقف في ظل غياب اي
مؤشر على حل النزاع بين المدربين وبين
مشغل قطارات وايضا يتهمون الحكومه لانها
لم تكن جده في ايجاد حلول لهذا النظام
مترو الانفاق تاثر ايضا او فقط القطارات
التي تربط المدن البريطانيه
همم هناك همم يعني بعض يعني التاخيرات في
القطار في همم في بعض الخطوط خاصه همم في
خط ال- همم يعني البني الذكر لاين يعني كل
القطارات التي لها محطات فوق الارض يعني
مرتبطه بمترو انفاق لندن
تاثرت بشكل او باخر تم تعليق بعد رحلات
مثلا لخط همم
في همم في غرب البلاد وبالتالي يعني هناك
بعض التاخير لكن مزاج العام في الشارع
البريطاني مؤيد لهذه الاضطرابات او متملل
منها
[موسيقى]
يعني تراجع كبير لمؤيد هذا الاضراب وخاصه
في وسائل النقل يعني الموضوع مختلف تماما
عندما نتحدث عن
اضراب الممرضين او اطقم الاسعاف ولكن في
وسائل النقل العام والقطارات بالتحديد لا
يؤيدون هناك تقريبا
43% فقط يؤيدون هذا الاضراب ولكن يعني
يعتذرون هؤلاء المضربون عن عن عن العمل
بسبب تجعل حياه الناس صعبه وحركه التنقل
شبه جحيم يعني في بريطانيا احيانا عندما
تكون الامور على هذا النحو شكرا لك من
لندن مراسل العربيه
اضحك انتشار وباء كورونا على نحو واسع في
الصين بعد تخلفين على سياسه صفر قفد يثير
المخاوف من ازمات تؤثر على امدادات
التجاره العالميه لتضاف ذلك الى ازمه
الحرب في اوكرانيا هذا في الوقت الذي تفرض
فيه الدول قيود على المسافرين اليها
القادمين من الصين
والحذر من وباءكر عبر العالم المخاوف شملت
امكانيه تاثر امدادات التجاره العالميه من
الصين لتنضاف بدورها الى ازمه الحرب
المستعره في اوكرانيا بعد رفع القيود
البلد الاكبر من حيث عدد السكان في قلب
اشد موجه من الوباء في العالم ما تسبب في
اثاره قلق العديد من الدول في ظل بيانات
غير موثوقه وتقديره جزئيه وشكوك حول ظهور
متحولات جديده
بلدان عديده بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
واسترا وكندا وفرنسا واليابان تعتمد على
عدم شفافيه البيانات الصينيه لتبرير
قرارها بفرض اختبارات خلو من الفيروس على
القادم من الصين هذا بالاضافه الى دول
قررت منع الوافدين منها من دخول اراضها
مثل المغرب
بكين وصفت القيود الدوليه المتزايده على
المسافرين من اراضيها بغير المقبوله وحذرت
من انها قد تتخذ اجراءات مضاده على اساس
مبدا المعامله بالمثل تحركات تنذر ببدايه
اغلاقه جديده شبيهه تماما بالعام 2020 في
ظل انتشار متحور شديد العدوى سمي بيوم
القيامه غير ان دول كثيره لن تغامر
بالاغلاق التام بالنظر الى الكلفه
الاقتصاديه الباهظه للقرار
بلال الوجدان العربيه
الموجز الرياضي مع محمد الغناس مساء الخير
[موسيقى]
ريما مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام قررت لجنه
المسابقات في رابطه الدوري السعودي
للمحترفين تاجيل لقاء النصر وضيفه الطائي
والذي كان من المقرري قامته اليوم ضمن
مباريات الجوله الثانيه عشر من الدوريات
السعودي للمحترفين لاقامه غدا الجمعه في
نفس التوقيت عند السادسه مساءا وجاءت جيل
بناء على خطاب رئيس مجلس اداره شركه
الوسائل السعوديه القاضي بعدم قدره ملعب
مرسول بارك في جامعه الملك سعود على
استضافه اللقاء نظرا لغزاره الامطار التي
ادت الى اعطال كهربائيه اناره الملعب
والبوابات الالكترونيه ويتم التاجيل حرصا
على سلامه اللاعبين والحضور في الملعب
لحسب بيان الرابطه الذي نشرت اليوم
يتواجه هو الاتحاد والهلال في كلاسيكو
لكره السعوديه الخميس ضمن مباريات الجوله
الثانيه عشر من الدوري في ملعب مدينه
الملك عبد الله الرياضيه بجده ويقع
والاتحاد في المركز الثالث برصيد 24
مباريات اخرى مؤجله مع الشباب بينما يحتل
الهلال المركز الخامس برصيد 22 نقطه مع
احدى 10 مباراه كان اخرها التعادل امام
المنظمات ويبحث الهلال عن الفوز بعد
التعثر في الجولتين الماضيتين بينما
يستمتعوا الاتحاد بسلسله من النتائج
الايجابيه اذا لم يخسر اي مباراه في
الموسم حتى الان
ويسعى الشباب الى خطف النقاط مضيفه الوحده
على ملعبي مدينه الملك عبد العزيز
الرياضيه بمكه المكرمه في مباراه يطمح
فيها اصحاب الارض الى الابتعاد عن مؤخره
الترتيب والضيوف والبقاء ضمن المنافسين
على الصداره واتراجع الوحده الى المركز
الثالث عشر برصيد 9 نقاط وله مباراه مؤجله
امام الفتح بينما ينفرد الشباب المركز
الثاني برصيد 25 نقطه مع مؤجل امام
الاتحاد
كاس الخليج لكره القدم في البصره العراقيه
وهي المره الثانيه التي يستضيف العراق
فيها البطوله بعد نسخه عن 79 والتي جرت في
بغداد اليوم الاول سيشهد لاعبه مباراه
سيلفي في المجموعه الاولى العراق صاحب
الضيافه سيواجه سلطنه عمان والسعوديه
تلتقي مع عليا
تاهل برشلونه الى ثمن نهائي كاس ملك
اسبانيا بفوز صعب على مضيفه احد فرق
الدرجه الثالثه
من برشلونه كتالونيا الى اليكانتي فالنسيا
حملت معها رباعيه وفوز بشق الالفوس تفاد
به المدرب الشعبي خروجا مبكرا من مسابقه
الكاس بدون ليفاندوفسكي والتير شتيجن
استهلا برشلونه المباراه بافضل ما يكون
هدفه في الدقيقه الرابعه اعطى املا بنتصار
كبير
صمد اصحاب الارض في باقي دقائق الشوط
الاول وانتظر انتر سيتي حتى مطلع الشوط
الثاني يدرك التعادل في مرمى الحارس
فيناستوريس صاحب الهدف سولد فيلا كان
السابقا يلعب في الشباب برشلونه بين 2018
و2020
موتور سيتي
الهدف الثالث لبرشلونه وبدا بان البرازيلي
ابطل مفعول مفاجاه فريق الدرجه الثالثه
قبل النهايه بثلاثه عشر دقيقه
مجددا
الاستسلام واكمل الهاتف الشخصي له في
الدقيقه السادسه والثمانين عن الوقت
الاصلي ينتهي والتعادل يجبر بطل الكاس في
31 مناسبه على حوض شوطين اضافيين
توالت فرصه برشلونه وتصديات الحارس وخشبه
الثلاثه
في الدقيقه الثالثه بعد المئه انتصارا
تاخر لكنه عندما تحقق عادل الفريق
الكتروني الى مقره برباعيه اكد التاهل الى
ثمن النهائي
الامور في الشوط الاصلي
دعى الجنين فانتينو رئيس الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم للتضامن مع ثنائي فريق ليتشي
سام والانتيتي ولميك باندا حيث اذان
الاساءات العنصريه التي تعرض لها الثنائي
اثناء مواجهه لاتسيو في مباراه بالدوري
الايطالي امس الاربعاء وعبر انفانتينو عن
طريق حسابي على انستغرام عباره عن تضامنه
معهم تيتي
متمنيا ان تقف الغالبيه العظمى من
المشجعين الطيبين لاسكات كل العنصريين مره
واحده والى الابد
جرت اليوم خامس مراحل ايرالي دكاره
السعوديه في منطقه حائل وتعرض السائق
الفرنسي ستريم الى حادثه في الكيلومترات
الاخيره اليوم ما افقده 20 دقيقه بات
القطري ناصر العطيه في صداره الترتيب يليه
هي الاسبانيه كالسينز بالمرتبه الثانيه
ونال الفرنسيه ادريان فامبير بطوله هذه
المرحله في فئاته الدراجات الناريه
الخامسه لكلمه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لمحمد وجه مسؤولون في ولايه
كاليفورنيا الامريكيه بالاسراع في عمليات
الاجلاء في منطقه ساحليه شديده الخطوره مع
قدوم عاصفه شديده وهطول امطار تسببت في
قطع التيار الكهربائي عن اكثر من 70000
شخص بمنطقه خليج السنفورسيسكو كما الغت
السلطاته وعشرات الرحلات الجويه وقررت
اغلاق المدارس في احدى الضواحي بالاضافه
الى التحضيرات للسكان شمال كاليفورنيا
بالابتعاد عن الطرق
قال انتيجاسي الرئيس التنفيذي لامازون في
مذكره للموظفين ان التخفيضات الوظائف في
الشركه ستطل اكثر من ثمانيه عشره وظيفه في
اطار تقليس للقوى العامله
امازون التي يعمل بها اكثر من مليون و500
الف شخص تستعد لتصريح اكثر من 18 الف موظف
الركود دفع شركات مثل النساء
على خفض الانسان
[موسيقى]